MMM,
we all want to have a good stable
relationship with somebody at one of the
problems with early stage intense
feelings of romantic love is that it's
part of the oldest parts of the brain
that become activated brain regions link
with drive,
with craving,
with obsession,
with motivation,
and in fact,
some cognitive regions up in the
prefrontal cortex that have evolved much
more reasonably begin to shut down a
brain region linked with this decision
making,
uh,
planning ahead,
um,
you know,
uh,
people were madly in love,
can fall madly in love with somebody
who's married who lives on the other
side of the planet,
who comes from a different religion.
And somehow they'll say to themselves,
we'll work it out.
We can work this out because of all that
energy of intense romantic love and also
the shutting down of various brain
systems like with decision making.
So one of the things that I say to
people is,
you know,
uh,
before you decide to marry somebody,
um,
spend some,
a good deal of time with them.
Uh,
so there's some of that early stage
intense feelings of romantic love can
begin to subside and you can begin to
really see what you've got is a matter
of fact.
I'm very optimistic about the future of
relationships because we're spending so
much time now getting to know somebody
before we were,
you know,
a great many people are having these one
night stands and friends with benefits
and a living together before they
married.
And there was a recent study which they
asked a lot of single people who were
living together with somebody,
um,
uh,
why have they not yet married?
And 67 percent were terrified of
divorce,
terrified of the,
not only the legal and the financial and
the economic,
but the personal and social fallout of
divorce.
And so began to,
I began to realize maybe all this
hooking up and friends with benefits and
living together is not recklessness.
Maybe it's caution.
Maybe singles are trying to learn every
single thing they can about a potential
partner before they tie the knot.
And in short,
marriage used to be the beginning of a
relationship.
Now it's the finale and I think that
that is very positive as a matter of
fact.
Um,
I work with match.com
and their senior,
other,
other chief scientific advisor.
And um,
we did a study of married people not on
the site match.com,
of course,
of 1100 married people.
And I had reason.
Well,
if there's this long precommitment stage
of getting to know somebody,
maybe by the time you walk down the
aisle,
you know what you've got,
you're happy with what you got and
you're going to build a long,
stable,
really happy marriage.
Maybe we're going towards a time of
happier marriages because relationships
can end before you tie the knot.
So with,
in this study,
I asked these 1100 married people,
um,
uh,
a lot of questions,
but one of the questions was,
would you remarry the person you're
currently married to?
An 81 percent said yes.
And I think that with what I call fast
sex,
slow love,
with this slow process of getting to
know somebody very carefully over a long
period of time,
it's going to help the brain readjust
some of these brain regions for decision
making.
You're going to get to know how this
person handles your parents at Christmas
or whatever holiday,
you know,
how they handle your friends,
how they handle their money,
how they handle an argument,
uh,
how they handle getting exercise and
their own health and your health,
et cetera.
You learn a lot about the person.
I think we're in a fair,
I'm very optimistic about the future
because of this concept of slow love.
I'm not really in the advice business,
uh,
or the business I think people should
marry when they feel like marrying.
But from what I know about the brain,
um,
if it were me,
I'd wait at least two years because in
two years you see the full cycle of the
year twice.
You see how they handle halloween,
how they handled Christmas or Hanukkah,
how they handle a summer fun.
Uh,
and to see,
see that twice is I think important.
And by the way,
you can sustain that intense feelings of
romantic love.
For two years I've studied 5,000
people through match.com,
not on the match.com
site,
a representative sample of Americans
based on the US census and a great many
of them say that they've had the
experience of sustained feelings of
intense romantic love for somebody for
two to five years.
So if you pick the right person and you
know how to sustain some of the joy,
uh,
I think you can create a longterm,
um,
attachment that is full also have
periods of romantic love.
We all want to sustain a longterm happy
partnership and psychologists will give
you a long list of smart ways to sustain
it.
But I'd like to say what the brain can
add.
I studied the brain and the first thing
that you want to do is sustain the three
basic brain systems for mating and
reproduction.
Sex drive.
Have sex with the partner,
have sex regularly with the partner.
If you don't have time scheduled a time
to have sex with the partner because
when you have sex with a partner,
a,
you're driving up the testosterone
systems so you're going to want to have
more sex,
but you also have all the cuddling which
is going to drive up the oxytocin system
and give you feelings of attachment and
having sex with the person,
uh,
any kind of stimulation of the genitals
drives up the dopamine system and can
sustain feelings of romantic love.
So basically having set and of course
there's,
there can be good jokes about it and a
relaxation about it that is good for the
body and the mind.
So have sex with a person and sustain
that brain system of this x drive to
sustain feelings of intense romantic
love.
Do novel things together.
Novelty drives up the dope immune system
and can sustain feelings of romantic
love.
And this isn't just in the bedroom.
Just go to a different restaurant on
Friday night.
Take your bicycle instead of a car,
a read to each other in bed.
Sit together on the couch and,
and,
and have a discussion about something
new.
Read new books together,
novelty,
sustained feelings of intense romantic
love.
You also want to sustain feelings of
deep attachment.
And to do that,
you have to just stay in touch.
Uh,
learn to sleep in the person's arm.
At least start that way.
Um,
cuddle a after dinner,
a walk arm in,
arm down the street,
hold hands together,
put your foot on top of his foot or her
foot while you're having dinner,
gently of course,
but stay in touch that drives up the
oxytocin system and can give you
feelings of deep attachment to the
partner.
So you want to sustain all three of
those brain systems,
sex drive,
feelings of romantic love and feelings
of deep attachment.
But we've also found out,
um,
what's going on in the brain in longterm
happy partners.
We did a study,
a brain scan study of people who were
married,
an average of 21 years.
And those people who were married an
average of 21 years who were still madly
in love with their partner showed
activity in three brain regions of brain
region linked with empathy,
a brain region linked with controlling
your own emotions and a brain region
linked with what we call positive
illusions.
The simple ability,
but sometimes it's hard to overlook what
you don't like about somebody and then
focus on what you do.
So last but not least,
um,
we've known known that,
if you say several nice things to your
partner every day,
um,
I would suggest five.
But if you can only pull off two or
three,
whatever,
say Nice things to your partner that
actually reduces their cholesterol,
reduces their cortisol,
which is the stress hormone and boosts
their immune system.
But it also boosts yours.
So what the brain says about a happy
longterm partnership is overlook what
your Dole.
I can focus on what you do,
be,
express empathy for the partner,
control your own emotions,
have sex with the partner,
do novel things together,
and stay in touch and say several nice
things every day.
And you will,
your brain will help you sustain a
longterm,
deep attachment.
We're built to.
We're built to love.